[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue au parlement européen
à strasbourg pour un nouveau numéro d'
europe hebdo émission spéciale avec
l'élection du président macron va-t-on
ouvert une relance du projet européen
c'est la question qu'on va se poser
aujourd'hui avec nos invités yannick
jadot
bonjour bonjour merci d'être venu à vous
êtes eurodéputée europe ecologie les
verts ancien candidat à la
présidentielle en france avant de
rallier la candidature du socialiste
benoît hamon merci d'être venu à côté de
vous franck proust bonjour bonjour à
vous êtes député français élu sous les
couleurs des républicains vous êtes
aussi un le chef de la délégation
française du ppe parti populaire
européen qui regroupe à la droite et le
parti du centre ici au parlement
européen merci d'être venu face à vous
andrea ce web pour jour vous êtes député
européen allemand et membres de la cd ou
à le parti d'angela merkel approche de
la chancelière me dit on avant de
débattre
retour sur ce premier déplacement du
président français comme françois
hollande ya cinq ans emmanuel macron a
réservé sa première visite de chef
d'état à la chancelière allemande angela
merkel qui adoube le nouveau président
français sur l'europe elle a fait des
gestes d'ouverture marquée en direction
du chef de l'état sur son projet de
fondation de l'europe en crise et elle
n'exclut pas de changer à les traiter on
regarde et on réagit juste après
[Musique]
il est arrivé sous le soleil et les
flashes des photographes
emmanuel macron est accueilli comme une
star à berlin où l'on voit en lui le
sauveur de l'europe on fait de notre
mieux lance le nouveau chef de l'état
chaque geste compte le président
français multiplie les attentions
emmanuel macron est le quatrième chef
d'état français avec lequel angela
merkel va coopérer
elle qui est au pouvoir depuis 2005
présentation très décontractée avec
l'ambassadeur à berlin philippe etienne
devenu le sherpa le conseiller
diplomatique d'emmanuel macron puis les
acclamations des partisans de pulse of
you drop
le mouvement citoyen pro européen né en
allemagne
ensemble ils écoutent les hymnes
nationaux
[Musique]
ensemble ils passent les troupes en
revue
ah c'est qu'ensemble ils veulent écrire
une nouvelle feuille de route pour
l'europe
la chancelière avait indiqué un peu plus
tôt elle ne veut pas accueillir le
successeur de françois hollande en
madame je sais tout et pas non plus dire
non à toutes les propositions
après cinquante minutes d'entretien avec
l'eau les deux dirigeants appellent à
une nouvelle dynamique de la relation
franco allemande
le couple franco allemand je crois a
besoin de réimprimer beaucoup de
pragmatisme et de volontarisme de court
terme et aussi de moyen terme pour
l'union européenne et la zone euro
et c'est dans cet esprit là que nous
allons travailler ensemble au-delà des
gestes d'amitié
angela merkel a laissé entendre sur le
fond que son pays était prêt des
évolutions des traités européens
c'est ce que souhaite aussi le président
français du point de vue allemand il est
possible de changer les traités si cela
fait sens vraiment nous avons besoin de
renforcer la zone euro pas seulement de
manière intergouvernementale en tant que
composant de l'europe nous avons besoin
de ces changements de traité le sujet
des changements de traité fut un tabou
français en l'espèce pour moi il n'y en
aura pas tous deux sont d'accord sur un
point il faut d'abord que la france se
réforme elle-même avant de demander des
réformes pour l'europe
ce dernier conseille dans gala merkel au
début de toute chose il y a un charme
mais pour que le charme de moeurs il
faut des résultats à la clé a tenu à
rajouter la chancelière
emmanuel macron à cinq ans pour mettre
cette maxime en pratique alors une
première réaction messieurs premier
déplacement réussi ou pas réussi les
manuels macron il exado réussi de toute
façon on n'a pas le choix il ya eu le
break site le statu quo en europe c'est
plus de break site c'est la victoire d
extrême droite des nationalismes et
c'est la défiance des citoyens européens
vis-à-vis de l'europe évidemment le
couple franco allemand
c'est pas avec theresa may convard fondé
l'europe c'est pas avec core ban
c'est pas avec quatre inscrits le vrai
dirigeant polonais et malheureusement la
situation politique en italie en espagne
ne leur permet pas des acteurs puissants
de cette refondation
donc oui aller vers un budget vers
l'investissement vert plus et mieux
d'europe
maintenant il y à des partis qui reste
flou sur cette première rencontre
moi j'ai entendu aussi un emmanuel
macron un peu comme un françois hollande
ya cinq ans dire on va d'abord faire
chez nous assumer cette discipline
budgétaire qui a quand même tué
l'investissement rendu notre croissance
atone et empêcher un certain nombre de
transformations vers la transition
énergétique le climat vers plus de
solidarité entre le nord et le sud là le
problème grec n'est toujours pas résolue
donc il ya aussi cette même démarche qui
continuent à dire faisons des réformes
structurelles chez nous avant d'en vivre
est formé de réformes et l'europe
et pourtant je crois qu'il ya des enjeux
absolument essentiel et qu'on peut
mettre en place rapidement
la bc aujourd'hui sort 60 milliards
d'euros par mois pour racheter de la
dette publique qui alimente plus tôt les
banques et la finance que l'économie
réelle
mettons ça dans l'économie réelle on n'a
pas besoin de changer les traités là
dessus ça permet de câbles
investissement et puis un sujet qui est
très fort emmanuel macron d'une certaine
façon est l'héritier en tant que
président de la république de l'accord
de paris sur le climat madame
qu'elle va recevoir au nom des fidji à
bonn à la fin de l'année la conférence
sur le climat
elle a toujours dit vouloir faire de la
transition énergétique et de la lutte du
raid contre le réchauffement climatique
un pli important je crois que là ça peut
être un axe important et populaire de
refondation de l'europe un grand projet
de leadership européen sur le climat
face aux climato-sceptiques trump et
poutine et puis surtout ce qu'avait été
souvent discutée entre hollande et
merkel une communauté européenne de
l'énergie ce qui a jamais voulu faire
hollande est ce que macron avec mérian
par les prend pas le faire sur ce couple
franco-allemand c'est vital pour
relancer le projet européen c'est
essentiel même si cette première visite
était quand même plus une visite
protocolaire
le but de cette visite c'était
d'annoncer la ligne directrice le cap
que souhaitez faire emmanuel macron mais
comme le disait yannick jadot on avait
eu la même scène il ya cinq ans j'ai le
souvenir d'un président hollande qui
voulaient réorienter l'europe qui avait
annoncé des structures et le problème
c'est que ce n'est jamais arrivé et
qu'aujourd'hui nos partenaires allemands
entendent que la france respecte ses
engagements il faut redonner la
confiance à nos partenaires ce qui
explique si vous voulez que on est pour
l'instant sur un catalogue de bonnes
intentions pour parodier une émission
bien connu en france des paroles et des
actes
andrea soir quand on voit emmanuel
macron autres outre-rhin en allemagne on
a vu qu'ils avaient beaucoup
d'applaudissements lors du déplacement à
saint sauveur de l'europe
il nous il nous a sous les jets soulager
beaucoup qu'il a eu une grande majorité
mais je pense le moment un moment clé
pour moi dans la campagne qui est un peu
confirmé dans cette visite à berlin
c'était le moment où il a dit vis-à-vis
à des journalistes comme vous quand on
lui a demandé qu'est ce que vous allez
faire face à madame merkel ont comme un
adversaire il a dit non je ne sera pas
face à elle je serai avec elle et c'est
ce qu'on veut faire en europe on veut
faire des choses ensemble et pour moi ça
a été très positif que quelqu'un peut
gagner en france ayant une parole
d'amitié mais comme l'a déjà été dit par
mes collègues c'est vrai que ça donne
des images très positif très joli mais à
la fin c'est les actes qui compteront et
donc on espère que la france reprendra
car c'est un point clé pour l'europe
pour l'économie européenne mais aussi
pour l'économie allemande
mieux à l'économie française mieux aussi
l'économie allemande merkel a elle même
est en période
électorale est-ce qu'elle en situation
pour négocier quoi que ce soit avec le
président bak rond pour l'instant bas
madame merkel est dans une position
assez confortable comme les dernières
trois élections d'été gagner je pense et
en plus pour l'allemagne c'est un c'est
un point fondamental l'europe sans une
france forte ne fonctionnera pas mais la
france forte c'est pas quelque chose
qu'on peut faire de l'extérieur c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut se faire en
france et c'est pour ça qu'on croise les
doigts pour le prochain gouvernement
alors les dossiers qui fâchent les
divergences entre berlin et paris
il ya le renforcement de la zone euro ou
encore comment bâtir une défense
européenne
mais priorité des priorités pour
emmanuel macron les travailleurs
détachés synonyme de dumping social on
regarde et on réagit juste après
[Musique]
c'est un sujet ultra sensible en europe
beaucoup exploité pendant la campagne
présidentielle
le dumping social des travailleurs de
l'est polonais hongrois roumains
conséquences de la directive européenne
sur les travailleurs détachés là paris
et berlin sont d'accord et souhaite
encadrer le travail détacher cette
directive permet à des entreprises de
l'union de faire travailler
temporairement des salariés de pays
membres tout en payant des cotisations
sociales dans le pays d'origine
la france et l'allemagne veulent
désormais l'interdire en obligeant le
travailleurs détachés à toucher le même
salaire que ses collègues nationaux
pour l'instant la refonte du texte
suscite un bras de fer avec l'europe de
l'est
mais à part cela les divergences entre
paris et berlin sont nombreuses en
témoigne la une du grand hebdomadaire
allemand der spiegel terreur freund
chéramy comprendre un ami qui pourrait
coûter cher
ce titre résume à la fois le soulagement
mais aussi la crâne de berlin depuis
l'élection d' emmanuel macron la crainte
de devoir solliciter le contribuable
allemand pour renforcer la zone euro
emmanuel macron propose de créer un
budget spécifique aux 19 pays de l'union
monétaire
géré par un ministre des finances et un
parlement de la zone euro l'allemagne
est plus réticente
encore traumatisé par la crise des
dettes souveraines déclenchée par le
naufrage de la grèce le pays est en
pleine campagne électorale et l'opinion
publique refuse de payer pour les pays
du sud
autre dossier délicat comment bâtir une
défense européenne pour faire face à la
multiplication des menaces terroristes
sur le principe les deux sont d'accord
seulement paris estime que berlin ne
contribue pas assez à l'effort militaire
rien débloqué emmanuel macron et angela
merkel sont prêts à s'entendre pour
faire avancer l'europe à premier conseil
des ministres franco-allemand se tiendra
début juillet pour aborder ces questions
européennes
alors les travailleurs détachés un sujet
exploité par l'extrême droite pendant la
campagne électorale est ce que la
réforme de la directive peut aboutir
yannick jadot il faut qu'elles
aboutissent faut déjà rappeler ce qu'est
cette directive à quoi elle sert elle
sert à protéger les salariés dans un
espace de mobilité
ça veut dire qu'un salarié français qui
va faire une mission pendant un mois
dans un autre pays ne sera pas n'aura
pas de rupture dans sa sécurité sociale
dans sa protection sociale
de la même façon dans la logique de la
directive un travailleur roumains
polonais qui vient en france sera orale
et les meilleures conditions de travail
en tout cas les mêmes conditions de
travail que les travailleurs français là
où parce qu'il faut le rappeler parce
que la france envoie aussi beaucoup de
travailleurs est assis sûr on a beaucoup
de pères et âgées là où il ya un
problème il ya deux types de problèmes
1 c'est qu'en fait on n'est pas obligé
aujourd'hui quand vous prenez dans le
bâtiment un travailleur polonais qui va
venir un mois vous n'êtes pas obligé de
le payer au même salaire qu'à
travailleurs français équivalent que
vous recrutez d'aurier pour cette
mission donc l'objectif de la réforme
c'est de passer effectivement d'un
minimum de respect la protection sociale
dans le cadre français à la même
rémunération pour le même travail et
qu'à partir de là on mettre en place une
mob une mobilité protéger des
travailleurs européens
le deuxième problème qu'on a à mettre à
résoudre au niveau européen c'est la
surveillance et le contrôle
le vrai problème qu'on a dans tous nos
pays c'est l'absence de contrôle c'est
les travailleurs détachés illégaux c'est
ce qu'ils sont exploités par une forme
de crime du travail des entreprises qui
les maltraitent et ça il va falloir
remettre en place et c'est ce qu'on
défend nous un corps d'inspecteurs du
travail européen pour bien vérifier que
un travailleur qui se déplace à la fois
va toucher le même salaire qu'à
travailleurs locales qui auraient pu
assumer mais surtout qu'il n'y ait pas
qu'ils soient pas exploités dans des
conditions scandaleuses
créé le dumping social trop crous la
réforme sur les travailleurs détachés
l'an cours d'examen au parlement repères
et déjà comme jolie que monsieur macron
veut engager la révision leur l'appâtant
du coup à la révision
ma collègue elisabeth morin-chartier
trava porter une de nombreux - puisque
effectivement comme le dit yannick jadot
s'est pas tellement la directive qui est
-ce qui est remise en cause et surtout
l'application frauduleuse de la
directive néanmoins il reste des
problèmes quand on parle salaire je
dirais même au delà c'est le problème du
coût global
c'est la problématique des charges
sociales la rémunération va parler
harmonisation fiscale c'est à dire mais
encore une fois quand on parle du
salaire et des charges et on regarde un
petit peu les pistes de travail
c'est que si par exemple un travail
roumain paye ses charges en france
bien sûr c'est un devoir mais il y aura
aussi des droits
ce qui pourrait poser problème je lisais
un article ce matin ou éventuellement un
travailleurs roumains qui travaillent en
france mais en laissant ses enfants
roumanie pourrait toucher les
allocations familiales françaises pour
ses enfants restent en roumanie dont
faut faire très très attention mais le
coup la durée la problématique des
agences d'intérim c'est à dire les
emplois en cascade sont des véritables
problèmes et il ya le contrôle parce que
le contrôle en france n'est pas le même
que le contrôle en roumanie ou en
pologne
et si je prends la législation française
alors c'est vrai qu emmanuel macron
avait déjà travaillé dans ce sens
puisqu'il avait impose une carte
professionnelle notamment sur les
chantiers mais moi qui suis un élu local
qu'est ce que je m'aperçois que c'est un
bon nombre d'entreprises qui travaillent
aujourd'hui le week-end le soir très
tard voire même la nuit et les
contrôleurs que nous avons en france ils
sont 35 heures il parle pas forcément
toutes les langues
donc aujourd'hui il ya 200 ans - ils
sont plus aptes il y en a de moins en
moins mais ils sont plus aptes à les
contrôler les entreprises qui sont
j'allais dire en adéquation avec délégué
la légalité que des entreprises qui
détourne la réglementation même actuelle
et qui utilise des gens dans des
conditions d'ailleurs déplorable à la
fois les week-ends et pendant les
périodes de nuit
andrea schoepp en allemagne on est
concerné par la concurrence déloyale
dumping social du travail des tâches est
bon le dumping social c'est une
expression que je n'aime pas trop car ça
n'a pas vraiment de sens et des
travailleurs qui aiment la mobilité
quand ils viennent de l'est et d'autres
qui le voient plus creed de manière plus
critique mais je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec ce qui a été dit par fera
pas franck prost car en fait c'est pas
la faute n'est pas à bruxelles comme on
dit souvent la faute et que les
administrations nationales sont pas
capables à s'adapter aux enjeux
européens
il faut changer ça en allemagne et
probablement aussi dans d'autres pays
si on veut contrôler on peut pas dire on
fait ça à l'allemande
il faut faire ça à l'européenne il faut
s'adapter à un mode plus européen
malheureusement aussi l'administration
allemand n'est pas vraiment arriver à
faire sur ce cas précis les travailleurs
détachés quand même des pays de l'est
qui bloque pour eux c'est une entrave à
la liberté de circulation des
travailleurs
non mais le contrôle de travail franck
proust a tout à fait raison peut pas
être bloquée c'est un devoir national
mais malheureusement on n'a pas trouvé
les bonnes pistes pour travailler
sérieusement là dedans et c'est ce qui
fait problème en allemagne mais
apparemment aussi chez nos voisins
français
est ce que vous pensez qu'ils vont se
laisser convaincre les pays de l'est
obliger les travailleurs détachés à
toucher le même salaire que leurs que
leurs collègues nationaux
moi je crois qu'il faut un pacte
politique globale aujourd'hui à
l'échelle européenne on n'arrivera pas à
traiter sujet après sujet sur les
travailleurs détachés
on aura beaucoup de mal avec les pays de
l'est si en même temps comme je le
disais tout à l'heure on parle pas
d'investissement pour relancer
l'ensemble de l'économie européenne
on pose pas la question des fonds de
cohésion c'est le deuxième budget
européen 3% du pib polonais c'est la
solidarité européenne
donc il refuse aussi les réfugiés il y à
la question de la politique européenne
de défense
donc on a tous des sujets sur lesquels
on a envie d'avancer
faisons un vrai pacte un vrai new deal
européen où on pose sur la table entre
européens
la question de la politique européenne
de défense qui la finance comment on
gère nos frontières extérieures la
question de l'investissement et de la
solidarité notamment vis-à-vis de
l'europe du sud
la question des travailleurs détachés et
d'une europe sociale qui peine
terriblement à exister
et puis un beau projet de civilisation
autour de la mobilité de nos jeunes et
puis de la question environnement post
sur le sujet il ya un effet conjoncturel
mais comme dans d'autres domaines la
défense ou la partie financière
c'est que les pays de l'est commencent
eux-mêmes à être concurrencé par et en
ukraine moldavie avec sérieux par le
moins disant social ils ressentent vous
savez quand les pays sont touchés par un
problème qu'ils ne connaissaient pas ils
sont plus enclins à être ouvert au 10 ou
par la dir est la directive donc
travailleurs détachés de nouvelle
mouture va être votée qu'en début à la
rentrée je moi enfin le calendrier a été
légèrement repoussé puisque cette bête
l'été je pense pour en avoir discuté
avec ma collègue lisabeth mans 1-1 il
vaut mieux tabler sur une fin d'année
2010 accor autres du taux elle sera mise
en oeuvre et mieux c'est on passe à
notre rubrique de fac checking nous
sommes confrontés avec la france a un
problème particulier les français
dépensent trop d'argent par rapport à
leurs dettes et ils dépensent au mauvais
endroit
qui a dit ça c'est jean claude juncker
et le président de la commission
européenne demande à emmanuel macron de
réduire la dépense publique
alors les français dépensent trop vrai
ou faux c'est checkpoint préparé par
thomas mignon
[Musique]
l'éternel problème de la dette publique
à peine élu en france emmanuel macron a
été mis en garde par le président de la
commission européenne
jean claude juncker français dépensent
trop d'argent les français consacrent
entre 53 et 57 % de leur pib à leurs
budgets publics
compte tenu du niveau relativement élevé
de la tête cela ne va pas fonctionner
dans la durée coquette
ces chiffres sont inexacts si on regarde
nos dépenses publiques françaises on
voit que dès 1991 1 les dépenses ont
toujours dépassé la moitié de la
richesse nationale produite en un an et
on le voit alors qu'en 2008 les dépenses
représentaient un peu moins de 53% du
pib français
dès 2009 elle atteignait 56 % sans plus
jamais redescendre sous ce palier et
cette proportion a même dépassé les 57 %
en 2014
la fourchette cité par jean claude
juncker est donc exact mais cela
signifie t'il et que la france dépense
trop au vu de sa dette
pour le savoir il faut se reporter aux
critères de convergence imposées par
l'union européenne dans la gestion des
finances publiques
un premier critère concerne le déficit
il ne doit pas excéder 3% du pib
or même s'il n'a fait que diminuer
depuis 2009 et la crise financière le
déficit français étaient encore de 3 4%
en 2016
autrement dit la france dépense
effectivement trop par rapport à ses
recettes et seuls trois autres états
membres ne respecte pas ce critère
seconde règle impose de ne pas dépasser
une dette équivalente à 60 % du pib
là aussi la france échoue avec une dette
à 96 % de son pib
notons que les mauvais élèves sont dans
ce cas ci plus nombreuses ces états
membres dont la belgique et bien sûr la
grèce bref dire que la france dépense
trop avec entre 53 et 57 % de son pib
consacré à ces budgets publics au lieu
des normes européennes
c'est vrai alors messieurs c'est quoi un
coup de pression en direction de la
france a respecté les règles européennes
à bord selon lesquelles il faut corriger
ça
ces critères-là n'ont pas été imposée
par l'europe ils ont été décidées de
manière démocratique y inclus le
gouvernement français donc il faut pour
éviter des malentendus dire ça
deuxièmement c'est clair que des pros
des déficits publics doivent pas
dépasser trois patients de s'imposer ça
a été décidé ensemble et deuxième point
je pense est évident que chaque pays
doit pas aussi régler les choses
internes avec son gouvernement à soi
même et donc c'est clair que les
décisions qui peuvent amener la france
sur une voie encore plus compétitive
devront se faire en france et je vous
rappel l'allemagne en l'an 2000 avec
schröder d'ailleurs a été le dernier en
europe avec des réformes on a pu avancer
assez rapidement en case est ce que vous
allez on se reprennent
est ce que freud heures avaient respecté
à ce moment là les normes de déficits
publics parce que pour faire ces
réformes il a beaucoup dépensé pour
investir dans son pays
donc c'était à l'époque où l'allemagne
et la france notamment ne respectaient
absolument pas les normes de déficits
publics ou confirmés je confirme c'est
bien mais donc s'il y a la volonté de
réformer il faut aussi un peu donner du
souffle pour un pays qui est en d'accord
donc investir avec ce qu'il s'est un peu
avant mais je dirais porto orthodoxie
budgétaire et investissement est ce que
c'est compatible
c'est le point essentiel mais le monde
vient de prononcer ni jadot est
essentiel aussi ses dires c'est
l'investissement le problème de la
france quand on a une dette qui avoisine
100% du pib
c'est qu'on croule sous nos dépenses de
fonctionnement or si on réduit pas le
train de vie de l'état
on peut pas dégager des marges pour
aller investir et l'investissement est
nécessaire aujourd'hui parce que c'est
la seule condition de ré en gendre et la
croissance au niveau de nos entreprises
et donc d'augmenter le pouvoir d'achat
de nos concitoyens
aujourd'hui on croule sûr on est on a
les ratios les plus élevés du nombre de
fonctionnaires par habitant c'est la
raison pour laquelle on a proposé c'est
une différence fondamentale entre les
gens de gauche et nous du nombre de
fonctionnaires de 300 milles dans le
programme des républicains parce
qu'aujourd'hui si on veut relancer
l'économie française
on a pas cinquante solutions c'est comme
dans un ménage quand on a des recettes
qui diminuent et bien on doit diminuer
nos dépenses pour essayer de se refaire
de l'autofinancement et le réinjecter
dans l'investissement c'est fondamental
pour la prendre il ya déjà de vous me
disiez tout à l'heure on n'a rien
compris quand on fait ses coups de
pression non à que juncker qui a quand
même été le patron du luxembourg et qui
a pillé nos finances publiques du fait
de son dumping fiscal viennent nous
donner des leçons de bonne gestion de
finances publiques
je trouve ça incroyable deuxièmement il
a il s'est tu pendant la campagne
électorale française
il a bien fait mais qu'il de nouveau il
envoie ce type de message
dans un moment politique et qui est
programmée au coeur et hilaire moscovici
a fait le même constat dans le
commissaire pays je trouve ça
prochainement mini ce droit est immense
et troisièmement un si la france est
aussi endetté au-delà des 60% c'est
parce que nous avons sauvé les banques
d'une crise financière que ses banques
ont généré donc il ya beaucoup d'argent
public qui a été sauvé un système
financier qui avait été particulièrement
perverse
dernièrement on et moi ce que j'aimerais
c'est que ce soit pas 55 53 à 57 %
le score du front national à la
prochaine élection présidentielle
donc pour ça ce que demandent les
français c'est aussi d'un service de
santé y compris dans les zones rurales
ils demandent de la culture ils
demandent de la bonne éducation et donc
on a besoin d'un état qui soit pro
allemand plus efficace mais un état qui
fournit des services publics où les
français se sentent moins pompeux la
doctrine fois et demie plus rapidement
si les européens dépensent plus qu'ils
ont c'est ce qui permet à l'allemagne de
faire beaucoup d'excès dans et que la
l'excédent allemand est tout aussi
illégale que les chiffres que vous avez
donnée au nom d'une règle libéral qui
est totalement absurde
dans le monde d'aujourd'hui donc il va
falloir un moment travailler ensemble
parce que si tous les européens comme
vous le demande et consomme moi c'est
l'allemagne qui produira moins et qui
aura moins d'excédent donc aujourd'hui
il faut travailler à faire que la
l'économie européenne soit plus
équilibrée mais beaucoup plus dynamique
avec les sujets de transition
énergétique de service public et de
transition numérique lâcher du lest sur
sur l'orthodoxie budgétaire
ça permet d'éviter la montée des
populismes de marine le pen il faut
faire attention pour ne pas donner de
scintillement pour les populismes et je
trouve et je suis très content positif
que yannick jadot lundi des
investissements se résoudront pas le
problème il faut aussi des réformes
il faut un état plus efficace et à faire
ça il faut aussi un cadre européen qui
est d'un pays en difficulté mais souvent
longtemps l'investissement c'est tout et
rien d'autre ça sauvera pas de mon point
de vue un pays ce sera le mot de la fin
merci à vous trois d'être venus débattre
avec nous et c'était très enrichissant
merci à vous de nous avoir suivis c'est
la fin d'euro penneteau à la semaine
prochaine vous retrouvez nos rames a dit
à bruxelles
d'ici là bonne suite des programmes sur
les chaînes parlementaires et la rtbf
ciao bye vis baltes à bientôt
[Musique]